programming throwdown episode 63 spring take it away patrick i wanted to talk about a sort of weird tangent interesting phenomenon and that is very small quadcopters with cameras on them so growing up as a child the you know very tiny spy airplane spy helicopter spy robot thing was always like a fascinating um thought for uh yeah i guess for a young child i mean in general they had remember honey i shrunk the kids when the kids got really small and they were kind of like you know flies literally flies on the wall size yeah yeah and so so now the technology for miniature electronics is and cheap electronics is getting so good that it's sort of culminating this thing that's just i guess some sort of phenomenon or whatever but it's called the tiny whoop so the tiny whoop is a small ducted fan quadcopter so the each of the so quadcopter has
four propellers on motors uh arranged in sort of a square around the center or an X, but around the center where the electronics and battery go. And the ducted part is means there's like a sort of a, what would you call it? Like a barrel, a small ring around the propeller that helps make it more efficient, but also means that if you like sort of run into something, the propellers don't stop and get caught. You can kind of bump into things. No big deal. Yeah. And so this thing being so small and ducted means you can fly it around
inside and it's sort of perfectly fine. It's light enough that it isn't really going to damage much. I mean, you should still be careful, but it's not dangerous. Like, uh, the,
the kind of Mavic pros, like you see people flying around the big outdoor quadcopters, you probably can't fly this outdoors because, uh, the wind is too big. Anyway, so it's a small ducted fan thing, and then someone put a really tiny camera on it so that it broadcasts to if you have first-person view goggles, which are basically goggles with little TV screens in them,
sort of like virtual reality screens, only there's not normally 3D information. Got it. And so you're able to sort of fly from a first person's perspective this tiny little thing and fly it around your house and so if you sort of watch the videos on the website or just go to youtube and type it in there's there's been new variants where they use other base quadcopter models to make the same thing but this sort of original tiny whoop is based off of a specific model and like it's kind of a specific setup but the idea
has kind of caught on these tiny little quadcopters that you fly around the house and you know sort of to make a racetrack out of your dining room chairs or uh whatever that sounds amazing well how much does this cost so i think that this setup which is the like the official quote-unquote tiny whoop setup is about uh like 175 dollars for the kind of quadcopter but then you need the goggles and a transmitter but the goggles and transmitters are like useful for more than just this setup like you could use them for other stuff gotcha so that entry price is pretty high you can do they have like sort of knockout versions i think you can get it all in for probably under a hundred dollars if you do the kind of not the kind of name brand stuff um right and it's still a little pricey like i don't to be fair have one but just like i'm fascinated by this
it seems like it's almost within reach for this like childhood dream of mine to be able to kind of like play a real life video game right yeah it sounds it sounds totally awesome they have basically did you see the uh racing the uh quadcopter racing it's the same it's exactly described they have the goggles uh but these ones are much bigger and they have this crazy obstacle course that they've built beforehand and they have to race through this obstacle course like wearing these vr goggles it looks awesome yeah so this is basically like for me playing pilot wings on the super nintendo right right like this is that in like real life that sounds amazing yeah we should uh yeah we should totally like split one or like you know get a get like a pool of people together because it's probably like all together around 300 bucks yeah but maybe if we
get you know we won't use it that much you'll get tired of it that's right that's the thing is like i mean if you're really into it you probably but but for me it's just like i just want to play around with it for a little bit it's it's probably so i did get a chance to try the dji mavic pro which is sort of like the newest and greatest um outdoor kind of quadcopter with camera that a lot of people are really excited about it's about a thousand dollars oh and it collapses down folds down into uh something that could fit in a large pocket like think a cargo pants pocket um and it hooks up to your phone really nice and i'll say i was surprised that is a very very well put i mean a thousand dollars is expensive but um is a very very well put together
kind of set up the quality of the quadcopter the kind of how the interface is thought out with using your phone as part of the controller um the quality of the video and they have a gimbal on it to make the video really stable and they have sort of cameras and i think ultrasound sensors or maybe just cameras to sort of look at the ground and sort of do stabilization so they sort of can fly to GPS points and do altitude hold but then at low levels they also do a lot of sort of computer vision to stabilize the quadcopter very accurately at low levels and so they have even like what they call like a tripod mode where you sort of fly it up and it it almost acts as if it's a camera mounted on a tripod just filming whatever you're kind of pointed at.
Wow. That's amazing. It's really slick. So if you're interested, you can go check out the videos. I think they even – I don't know if sold out is the right word, but I think there was like – it's been hard to get one. It's like a back one. They've been so popular. Yeah.
And again, it's – I don't know. I can't really justify because if you – I guess if you went hiking amazing places that had clearance to fly these, they'd make for awesome videos. I don't go enough interesting places to want to record video of where I go from a drone or from anything, to be fair. That would be cool while you're hiking to get, like, really cool aerial shots of you hiking and stuff. But $1,000 is pretty steep. I mean, it'd be dollars is pretty steep. Yeah.
And it'd be great if you could rent one. The fact that they're becoming down to the price where it's an individual could own it, not like a video company or, uh, you know, a group of people, it's,
it's kind of crazy. So I look forward to the future when, you know, hopefully these things continue to get better and drop in price. And everybody walks around with little flying drones over their head, recording everything. Oh, great. But anyway, so tiny whoop that's my like something of nostalgia sort of triggered when i saw this and i was like oh i really want to play with one of those so check it out let us know if you end up uh getting one or playing with that because it
sounds awesome i just realized if anyone ever even says the word pilot wings i have to play it now pretty much the rest of my night has been decided i was trying to teach my kid how to play it but they're still too it didn't work out very well that's pilot wings is a tough one yeah so even mario is tough you know at that age a lot of games are actually tougher than i remember i had way more time when i was a kid than i do now yeah exactly um cool time for the news my first link was a tutorial on writing a graphics shader so i think a while ago i had either as my tool of the show or something i had shader toy which is a web website where it uses web gl and allows you to sort of write your own shader to to kind of play cool animations or do some effects and we talked about it briefly anyway so this link we have um is a tutorial for how to get started writing your own shader on and it uses shader
toy as an example and and sort of walks through the explanation of what shaders are and what they do and how they work it also serves as sort of an intro in some levels to kind of graphics programming um and i just thought it was a really well put together tutorial i haven't had a chance to sort of follow all the way through but i sort of skimmed it and saw the approach they were taking and i'm actually excited to i want to kind of try this out because low level graphics programming is not the best place to spend your time if you want to write a game but it always seems like a very interesting aspect of doing that yeah totally yeah i mean super fun it's like parallel processing linear algebra it's like touches a lot of like things that are really really fun yeah and it's a lot of the when you learn about these things you'll sort of recognize them when you play games
often you know like oh they're doing this or doing that uh so anyways we'll have the link in the show notes because i'm not gonna it's like a very long link, so I'm not going to check it out. Yeah, check it out if you're interested in it at all. And I think it's cool. It's visual. And, you know, a lot of these things kind of walk you through kind of the whole process, which is really cool. Check it out. So my news is a pretty cool thing. It's some folks at Microsoft building an underwater data center. And these guys literally did this. They have these huge pipes and each pipe has a rack, you know, inscribed in the pipe and you have all the wires, switches and everything. Then they have, you know, a huge high cable um coming out of the
often you know like oh they're doing this or doing that uh so anyways we'll have the link in the show notes because i'm not gonna it's like a very long link, so I'm not going to check it out. Yeah, check it out if you're interested in it at all. And I think it's cool. It's visual. And, you know, a lot of these things kind of walk you through kind of the whole process, which is really cool. Check it out. So my news is a pretty cool thing. It's some folks at Microsoft building an underwater data center. And these guys literally did this. They have these huge pipes and each pipe has a rack, you know, inscribed in the pipe and you have all the wires, switches and everything. Then they have, you, know, a huge high cable um coming out of the
data center right so you can get the information out but yeah the whole thing's underwater so as a result they don't need any cooling or anything like that um it's super interesting tons of pictures of the whole process um they actually i guess because of the heat and just being a surface on the water, it grew a lot of organisms on the data center. So there's just a lot of sea creatures living on the surface of the data center, which is fine. And yeah, but they talk about how they get the electricity and stuff like that. It's a really, really cool article. Give it a read if you have some time no i'm distracted i want to envision where are other interesting places you can
put data centers oh um i mean i think underwater is the best because so like i guess you could use like the thermal heat to make your power? Oh, yeah. You could, but now cooling would be tough. Yeah, now cooling is a problem. I mean, they do a lot in places that have waterways. Like they basically build a dam. It's a dam and a data center all in one. But yeah, there's some kind of in the desert area, and they're all run by solar farms.
Yeah, normally where cheap electricity is. Yeah, exactly. So if you have a data center, a cluster of many computers, and you wanted to do some machine learning on it, you could use TensorFlow 1.0, which just came out. That's right. That was my bad attempt at a segue. So TensorFlow announced that they hit their 1.0 milestone. There's a lot of sort of low-level things that I guess they improved. And I'm not a TensorFlow developer,
but the one that caught my attention here is they're sort of feeling that their Python API has become stable, which means that for releases going forward, they don't feel like it's going to change dramatically, which means you can kind of depend on it being close to what it is today. And every time they change it, you're not going to have to go update a whole bunch of code. Right. Yeah. Very cool. Yeah. TensorFlow is great. Um, you know, I highly recommend it. I think, you know, I, I, uh think I've used R, I've used MATLAB, but going to NumPy for me was great
because there's a lot of file IO and different format handling and all these things that are really a pain to do in MATLAB or R. You end up having to do them in C or anyways versus Python has support for everything. So I used NumPy for a while and Theano and all that, and TensorFlow is just a cut above all of that. So it's really good to see that it's stable and it doesn't sound like it's going away anytime soon. So my article is, why are Indian engineers afraid of AI, afraid of artificial intelligence? And it's a super interesting article. I mean, it touches on a lot of different parts of Indian culture and things like that, that I knew nothing about until I read the article.
One interesting thing that it really made me think about is apparently in India, but I feel like it's also true here in the US, there's a lot of pressure to be a manager. And so, you know, if you have to spend all of this time and energy learning a specialty, like an individual special skill like AI, or if you want to be like a super expert in databases or just a super expert in graphics or something like that, that's time that you could be spending getting an MBA and like going the manager route. And so, you know, this is true everywhere, but I guess particularly in India, it's just very hard to get people to specialize in these sort of individual kind of specialities for this reason. Everyone wants to get an MBA and be a manager. And I thought this was kind of interesting. I'd be
interested to hear what you think about it as well, Patrick. But I think a lot of companies here in Silicon Valley do a pretty good job of making sure that there isn't like a you know an economic or a game theoretic incentive to being a manager that it's basically you know you can be a manager you could be you could specialize and they don't kind of set up the company so that one is just obviously better than the other and so that that helps um you know, encourage more people to specialize. But I think in general, this is just a big problem. I mean, if you look at the CEO, the CEO isn't an AI person most of the time. Most of the time, the CEO is someone who manages the people under them. And so there's this sort of implication that that is sort of the way to
the most fulfilling life. And it'll be interesting, especially, you know, the demand for CS specialists in a variety of fields is extremely high. It'll be interesting to see sort of how we deal with this as a society. For AI in particular, I feel that the background you need, at least currently, to be able to kind of create AI solutions or, you know, the sort of deep learning neural network, the stuff that's hot right now. You need background in a lot of things that take just a certain amount of time spent working on those things to get to that specialty. specialty um you can kind of work in the frameworks or hooking up bits of existing frameworks together but kind of like actually from scratch figuring out a correct solution to the problem and making sure that the ai solution or the machine learning solution is actually appropriate for your problem
like the kind of understanding for that seems to require uh relatively compared to doing other stuff in computer science investment and getting enough learning to be able to do that well. Yeah, that makes sense. And so I think the manager thing is an interesting twist on it, which is to say that, you know, you could spend all of that time becoming a manager instead, except that I think being a manager, people who, in my experience, has been people who are good at engineering don't always want to do the things that managers sort of need to do to be good managers. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, I agree 100%. So if you enjoy, you know, sitting down at code and hacking on it and solving a problem and optimizing something and thinking through clever new solutions, I mean, that doesn't say you won't also enjoy problem solving human conflict and negotiating deadlines and doing software estimation. But those two aren't as close as I think people often assume they might be. And so often you find engineers
convert to being managers and become unhappy because they actually prefer doing what they were doing before. And I think sometimes, like you said, often companies try to set it up so that you don't have to do that. Like you don't have to become a manager to get a promotion, or at least in most of the engineering companies I've worked at, that hasn't been the case. You can still get promoted as a technical contributor. But it often seems that there's more competition for the technical contributor than, say, a manager. But I don't know if that's just perceived and that management is actually also very tough because the buck sort of stops there. And if you mess it up you know it's
very easy to kind of not get fired i don't think but you know just kind of not get the sort of credit or the compensation that you would want because your scene is not performing yeah yeah i think uh i think there are pros and cons to both um i actually really i feel pretty good about um this this issue like the issue being you know in this particular article uh people you know everyone wanting to go into management but i think you know the the trend is already kind of shifting the other way like there's a lot of people with mbas and uh so I think the pros of specializing, even as an individual contributor, are starting to really stand out.
And so my guess is this sort of like pressure to like climb the ladder by being a major is going to get kind of less and less. Yeah, we've never really talked about it, but I've always struggled to see that we haven't kind of come and less yeah we've never really talked about it but i've always struggled to see that we haven't kind of come across a great and i don't maybe other industries have it or don't have it but there never seems to be a consensus on like what is a good team structure so often you end up on a project that says they were trying to be very flat you know very essentially very large
numbers of engineers to relatively few managers. But then there seems to be some pendulum that swings back the other way and says that's actually too difficult for the managers to sort of figure out what's going on. So then we need to organize the engineers into groups. And whether you like it or not, that sort of works away from flat and into sort of hierarchies and then back and forth. This is sort of way off topic of the article. But I just sort of have never topic of the article but i just
sort of never heard or seen or found a company that is trying to grow and change um maybe stable companies is different but companies which are under growth and change and new projects and new work and that kind of stuff that have found a good balance of what the a good team composition really looks like yeah i agree 100 super hard problem um yeah i think i feel like every i feel like there's progress like you know i definitely see i feel like things are better now in general when i hear anecdotes from people and things like that than you know maybe five or ten years ago um but yeah it's still totally unsolved problem all right time for book of the show my book of the show is the divine comedy which is a very old book it's written by dante
alighieri and it's about um it's a fiction book about his uh journey into uh the center of earth which is hell so in his book he goes through all the different I can't remember it's like the rings of hell I think it's yeah the rings of hell he gets to hell which at the center of the earth he actually passes through that and I guess once you go through in this story once you go through the center of the earth, you come up on, you start to approach the surface from on the other end of the earth, right? And that's where purgatory is and so on and so forth. And he explains all this.
The reason why I'm reading this is just over the years from you know everything from game of thrones with the giants to uh um to like uh net hack and dungeon crawl these games that have literally have the demons and the fiends from from from uh dante's uh the divine comedy um in in them and uh you know it's just you see the same kind of it's kind of like reading hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy like you see so many of these references like greek mythology and things like that that are all contained in in dante's inferno and other books um then i felt like i was going to kind of bite the bullet and read this sort of classic um it's pretty hard to read because the whole the entire thing is a poem
it's written in like a poem format so it's just pages and pages and pages of poems um so yeah but i'm making my way through it but one kind of cool thing i found out along the way is and i remember hearing about this every now and then but i never really looked into it is project gutenberg which is basically uh all of the public domain books that they can get their hands on, which I think they're up to like 53,000. They have curated in like electronic format and it's very high quality. The photos are high quality. They have Mobi, EPUB, PDFs. They have all the right formats um and you know they had the divine comedy and if if you want to read a book like alice in wonderland or any of these books 1984 any of these books that
uh you know is in the public domain um you can get it from this website it's probably the best version you're going to get um so yeah that's that's's my book of the show. Yeah. You weren't kidding about old. It was written in 1320. Yeah. Now they have like, uh, different versions. Obviously it's written in Italian. Um, the version, uh, that I'm reading is actually relatively recent. Like I think it was written in the past 50 years or so. Um, but yeah, it's still like pretty hard to read.
My book is not old. It's actually quite new. And it's A Night Without Stars by Peter F. Hamilton. And this is, I've had several Peter Hamilton books on 65, or no, 63 episodes. I'm sure I've had more than a few. And this is part of his Commonwealth saga, specifically the Fallers part of that. He has sort of a trilogy and is it duology?
I don't know, whatever, two books. Maybe. So I think in his Commonwealth saga, there's like a duology, a trilogy, and then this one is a duology. So there was a previous book, and then this is the second book, and this is called Chronicle of the Fallers. The first one was Abyss Beyond Dreams.
I don't know. These are just words. I have to look up. The titles sound awesome. Abyss Beyond Dreams. And this is Night Without Stars. And it's about the same. So it's the second book to this other one.
And it kind of wraps up the series. And I guess I was reading it. It sounds like he has sort of saying this is the last book in the whole commonwealth saga um so if you've not read anything in peter f hamilton's world don't start here this is sort of like very very late slash maybe even the end of the commonwealth saga um all together but the world he's sort of created in this sci-fi um book which they're all they're really big books so uh i think in total like with all of the books it's something that somebody said like 8 000 pages or something oh 5300 pages sorry um 5300 pages in total so it's you know it's an
investment but um he he creates a world that is deals with a lot of things that i find very interesting so sort of what happens when a society goes post-scarcity that you know things are very different why do people do what they do when humans can augment their body with you know technological enhancements some people want to some people don't some people take it to an extreme um some people there sort of becomes a middle ground of how you modify your body. What happens if you can sort of, you know, rejuvenate your body down to a younger age. So, you know, aging becomes sort of optional. Like what age would you sort of walk in at and what age would you stay? And, you know, if you
wanted to kind of become a little bit of an older person, it's almost becomes an eccentric affectation that like, oh, that's a 45 year old person. Like, wow. Like, interesting. I wonder why they let themselves be 45 instead of staying at 20. Oh, wow. And there's a lot of interesting concepts. And then there's aliens as well and how aliens can be so very different than humans but also sometimes the same uh anyways there's a lot of good stuff in his book and he has it's really thought-provoking after i always
whenever i finish one of his books i always find myself like really excited to like invent something or like i want i want the thing that he's describing in his book you know i want to like go i guess sort of isaac asimov um or arthur c clark sort of did the same thing right they described satellites before satellites were a thing they described space travel before we went into outer space and people kind of i could very much imagine feeling the same way now me reading their books i appreciate them they're good books but they don't inspire in the same way because they sort of described something that has already been described by others and that we've also sort
of entered into that future. Right. But this, I sort of feel maybe gives me the same feeling that people reading those had, you know, 30 years ago, or I don't know the right number of years ago. But kind of reading about satellites before the first Sputnik went up,
right. Would have been just crazy. And so for this, I sort of reading about the stuff the first Sputnik went up, right. Would have been just crazy. And so for this, I sort of reading about the stuff that it's like, well, I really hope one day people are inspired to co-invent these things. Yeah. It sounds awesome.
Yeah. I wonder, wouldn't it be crazy? I mean, if they invented a way to slow, you know, to, to slow aging,
but they did it kind of so late that we're already like 60 or 70 i'd probably just uh i don't know it's a tough call um but yeah that book sounds awesome i'll totally read it once i'm done reading about hell i'll read it well don't go read this one go back and read i think the first one is pandora's box oh okay pandora's star sorry pandora's Star. Sorry, Pandora's Star. Yeah. Is, I believe, the first one in the Kamen Rider Saga. So. Cool. And I will read them using Audible. I've started kind of getting into audiobooks.
The biggest thing was, like, I find my eyes are hurting. And really, it's because I think I'm on my phone too much. Like, I used to be on the computer maybe six, seven hours a day. And to be on the computer, maybe six, seven hours a day. And now I'm still on the computer six, seven hours a day, but I'm on my phone maybe four hours a day. And it's just too much. I don't know if those numbers are totally accurate, but I realized that I'm just looking at screens way too much. And so I've started doing audio books. I've also started getting into drawing. I, I, uh, uh, getting into a pencil drawing with an actual pencil instead of using, uh, you know, Photoshop. Um, and, uh, yeah, I think Audible is pretty awesome for being able to listen to the
books and kind of just close your eyes and, uh, or if you're driving, uh, don't close your eyes, but, uh, not not not crash into anybody um but be able to like you know kind of uh give your eyes a break from the computer screen or the kindle or what have you yeah i mean i love it for my commute so this book that i was just saying that i i just finished a night without stars is 26 hour 26 and a half hours long so you know you could sit there and read a book like you said but'm already, it's like three days of driving in the Valley, right? Yeah. I mean, I could tell you it's unfortunately not as long as I would wish it was to take to finish as I finished them more quickly. I'm always surprised at how fast I make it through a 40 hour book or a 25 hour book or a 20 hour
book. Um, and then when you get kind of eight hour books, which are kind of normal novel size, it's just like, you know, yeah, that doesn't even last a week. Um, and, uh, anyways, but yeah, so listening to audio books is great to pass the time. If you, if you commute on the bus or you drive or, um, you know, spent any amount of time where you kind of like, like Jason said, you either don't want to sit there staring at your phone for the length of time or for me like on a bus or train like i get sort of sick looking at my phone um from the vibrations then audible is a great way to still sort of enjoy enjoy content and of course podcasts but um you know it was a great way to enjoy books that you might otherwise not get a convenient opportunity to read that's right um we also so check out audible you can go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown all one word and we have a link to that in the show
notes as well and you could get started on your free trial um you can also support the show through patreon um patreon.com slash programming throwdown. And that really helps us out. It goes directly to server costs, setting up the T-shirt stores, things like that. We actually use tons of terabytes of data a month. And so the contributions help cover that. We also occasionally do raffles. A couple of lucky subscribers got a couple t-shirts i verified the t-shirts actually got there so uh um so you know who you are we called
笔记，你也可以通过Patreon支持我们，网址是patreon.com斜杠programming throwdown。这真的对我们很有帮助。它直接用于服务器成本、搭建T恤商店之类的事情。我们实际上每个月要消耗数TB的数据。所以这些赞助有助于承担这些费用。我们偶尔也会搞抽奖。有几个幸运的订阅者拿到了一些T恤，我确认T恤确实寄到了，所以呃，所以你们知道自已是谁，我们在上期节目里点名了
you out last show and you should have your t-shirt if if by some crazy reason you don't and someone else picked up your t-shirt let me know but that shouldn't happen. All right. Well, time for tool of the show. Tool of the show. This is a total cop-out. But I built my own tool and I want to talk about it. I don't think that's a cop-out. I feel like that's overachieving. Maybe, yeah. So basically, I wanted a SSH-like thing that lasted forever.
你们，你们应该已经拿到T恤了，如果因为某些疯狂的原因你没有收到，而且别人拿了你的T恤，请告诉我，但这不应该发生。好了，又到了每期一宝（tool of the show）的环节了。每期一宝。这完全是个敷衍。但我自己做了个工具，我想聊聊这个。我觉得这不算敷衍。我觉得这算超水平发挥。也许吧，对。基本上，我想要一个永远不会断开的类似SSH的东西。
It survived. I'm always on the forever. You know, it survived. Like if I, you know, I'm always on the go. Like I'm on my laptop, but I'm SSHed into a machine in a cluster where I do all of my work. I don't do any work on my actual laptop. All my work is done remotely. And so I'm SSHed into that machine. And so, you know, I'd close my laptop, I'd go to a meeting, I open my laptop, and the connection's dead.
它能存活。我一直在。你知道的，它能存活。就像如果我，你知道的，我总是在奔波。就像我在用笔记本电脑，但我通过SSH连接到了集群里的一台机器上，我所有的工作都在那里完成。我不在我的实际笔记本电脑上做任何工作。我所有的工作都是远程完成的。所以我SSH连接到了那台机器上。所以，你知道的，我合上笔记本电脑，去开会，我打开笔记本电脑，连接就断了。
Or I close my laptop, go to on the shuttle, open my laptop, connection's dead. And you have to do this goofy thing with SSH, you do like tilde period to kill the connection, because it doesn't think it's dead. And you have to go back into ssh they have to use screen and it's just it was just a huge pain so uh um so yeah i built this thing called eternal terminal um it's pretty cool it takes a little bit of setup i built a little
或者我合上笔记本电脑，坐班车，打开笔记本电脑，连接断了。你必须对SSH做那种滑稽的操作，比如输入波浪号加句点来断开连接，因为它不认为连接已经断了。你得重新进入SSH，你得用screen，这简直是个巨大的痛苦，所以，呃，所以，是的，我做了一个叫“永恒终端”（Eternal Terminal）的东西，挺酷的，需要一点点设置，我建了一个小
website explaining how it works um you have to install something on your uh laptop or on your you know client you have to install a piece of software on the server as well. And then it will actually use SSH to kind of start the connection. So you still have to have an SSH server, but most people do. It'll kind of negotiate the eternal terminal connection. And then after that, you're solid so um from kind of the user perspective it's just replacing ssh with et so you do et you do the location of the server um and it will do everything else handle all the negotiation and then boom you have a terminal um and it's just there forever so if you open up your laptop i
网站解释它是如何工作的，你必须在你的笔记本电脑上或在你的（你知道的）客户端上安装一些东西，你还得在服务器上也安装一段软件。然后它实际上会用SSH来建立连接。所以你仍然需要一个SSH服务器，但大多数人都有。它会协商永恒终端的连接。在那之后，你就稳了，所以从用户的角度来看，它只是用et替换了SSH，所以你输入et，加上服务器的位置，它就会处理其他所有事情，处理所有的协商，然后，轰，你就有了一个终端，而且它就永远在那里了，所以如果你打开笔记本电脑，我
actually closed my laptop i had a terminal running top which people don't know top is this unix command that every second or two it prints out the you know state of the computer like the processor usage and things like that um so i had Top going inside of an eternal terminal. I closed my laptop. I opened it about three days later and it actually like fast forwarded through all of the Top. Like in other words, like all these numbers started flying by and basically Top was catching me up on the state of my machine, you know, for all those seconds for the whole three days. But it fast forwarded all the way to the present and then it just kept going. So I'm pretty happy with it. I'm still working on getting it like into Ubuntu and Debian and
其实合上了笔记本电脑，我当时运行着一个叫top的终端，大家可能不知道，top是一个Unix命令，每隔一秒或两秒，它就会打印出计算机的状态，比如处理器使用率之类的信息，所以我当时在永恒终端里运行着top。我合上了笔记本电脑。大约三天后我打开它，它实际上像快进一样跑完了所有top的输出。换句话说，这些数字开始飞速滚动，基本上top让我了解了我的机器在这三天里每一秒的状态。但它一直快进到现在，然后就继续运行了。所以我对它挺满意的。我还在努力把它弄进Ubuntu和Debian以及
some of these, you know of these Linux OSs, like getting it built in, which is really interesting. I've never done that before. So in the meantime, you have to do a little bit of finagling, get it to work. You have to install an RPM from file and stuff like that. But yeah, it's coming along and it does the job. And if you do a lot of SSH, check this out.
一些这样的Linux操作系统里，把它内置进去，这真的很有趣。我以前从没做过。所以在此期间，你得稍微折腾一下才能让它运行。你必须从文件安装RPM之类的东西。不过是的，它正在进展中，而且能完成任务。如果你经常用SSH，去看看这个吧。
After that overachieving bit of awesomeness, mine is simply a website, myminifactory.com. If you've heard of Thingiverse, this is sort of similar. It's a place for 3D models. I have a 3D printer. This website, I don't know. Thingiverse has sort of almost everything but it's sort of hard to find the kind of best stuff um this is a little more selective
在那个超长发挥的精彩工具之后，我的是一个网站，myminifactory.com。如果你听说过Thingiverse，这个有点类似。这是一个提供3D模型的地方。我有一个3D打印机。这个网站，我不知道。Thingiverse几乎什么都有，但很难找到最好tipo的东西，这个在内容上更有选择性一点
in what they have it has a little less but it tends to kind of be more interesting uh on average i guess um and so if you have a 3d printer or want to be inspired as to why you should want a 3d printer then you should check out myMiniFactory.com. They have all sorts of weird smash-ups between different funny characters, like I'm looking at apparently a bender head statue on top of a Buddha. Okay, I don't, yeah. Oh my gosh. Interesting.
它拥有的东西少一点，但平均来看往往更有趣一些，我想，所以如果你有一台3D打印机，或者想找点灵感来看看你为什么应该买一台3D打印机，那么你应该去看看myMiniFactory.com。他们有各种各样不同搞笑角色之间的奇怪混搭，就像我正在看的，显然是一个放在佛祖头顶上的本德（Bender）头像雕像。好吧，我不想，是的。哦天哪。有趣。
There's lots of sort of fan art for, you know, lightsabers. Here's a magical fishing hook from moana um you know just all sorts of interesting trinkets i don't know they're particularly useful um but they're sort of fun and um if you like kind of using a 3d printer to print out things that uh are sort of unique that if you didn't have a 3d printer you probably wouldn't have then there's a great site to go to so can So if you print a 3D toy for your kids, let's assume your kids are over the stage where they eat everything, right? Is it safe?
这里有很多粉丝艺术，比如光剑。这里有来自《海洋奇缘》的神奇鱼钩，各种各样有趣的小玩意，我不知道它们有多实用，但它们挺好玩的，如果你喜欢用3D打印机打印一些独特的东西，如果没有3D打印机你可能就不会拥有，那么这是一个很棒的网站。所以如果你给孩子们打印一个3D玩具，我们假设你的孩子们已经过了什么都往嘴里塞的阶段，对吧？这安全吗？
If my son is running and he falls with the toy, is it going to splinter and disarm or something? I'm not a lawyer. I would not give child safety advice yeah this is yeah not good point okay yeah for this total disclaimer here this is our opinion and don't try i mean i let my kids play with them the pla so while you're printing so my printer lives in the garage um and i have webcam set up to monitor it um because there is some sort of sometimes when you're doing printing they're sort of grinding gears on the plastic and the plastic kind of gets into little bits of dust
如果我儿子在跑步，拿着玩具摔倒了，它会碎裂然后伤到人吗？我不是律师。我不会提供儿童安全建议，是的，这不是个好点子，好吧，是的，对于这个完全免责声明，这是我们的意见，不要尝试，我是说我让我孩子们玩那些PLA（聚乳酸），当你打印的时候，我的打印机放在车库里，我装了网络摄像头来监控它，因为有些时候当你打印时，塑料会磨损齿轮，塑料会变成一些微小的灰尘颗粒
that float around in the air and you wouldn't want to breathe that in um and depending on the kind of plastic you're printing but the most common ones are abs and pla um and abs is often used for like drinking water pipes. And PLA is used for the compostable plastic cups, if you ever see those. Oh, okay. It's like a corn or can be corn based biodegradable thing. And so I, you know, my kids don't put things in their mouth. So I'm not too worried about it. If they tripped and fell i mean it's they have little
漂浮在空气中，你不会想把那些吸进去的，这取决于你打印的塑料种类，但最常见的是ABS和PLA，ABS经常用于饮用水管。而PLA用于可堆肥的塑料杯，如果你见过那种的话。哦，好吧。这就像玉米或可基于玉米的生物可降解的东西。所以，我，你知道的，我的孩子们不会把东西放进嘴里。所以我不太担心。如果他们绊倒并摔倒了，我是说他们也有小型压铸玩具，我，你知道的，这看起来没那么糟糕，是的，那是真的，但是的，我不是律师，我不是儿童安全专家，你，你是，是的，如果你们给孩子玩具玩，你们的孩子可能会死，如果你给，如果你让你的孩子，如果你的孩子有任何乐趣，他们可能会死，你知道的，我曾经有一个化学套装，里面实际上有镁条，就像你可以制造凝固汽油弹和所有这些东西。就像它有制作凝固汽油弹的说明书。我给我表弟的孩子买了一套化学套装。结果就像什么都没有一样，每样东西都是可食用的。就像你实际上什么也做不了。
die cast toys as well i you know this seems less bad than that yeah that's true but yeah i'm not a lawyer i'm not a child safety expert you you're yeah yeah your kids will probably die if you give them toys to play with if you give if you have your kids if your kids have any fun they might die you know i had a chemistry set that actually had magnesium strips and like you could make napalm and all this stuff. Like it had instructions for making napalm. And I got a chemistry set for my cousin's kid. And it was like nothing, like everything was edible. Like you can actually do anything.
你唯一能做的就是做一个火山喷发模型什么的。这就像事情变得太温和了。是的。不管怎样。我并不反对，但我不是律师。我不会建议你教你的孩子制作凝固汽油弹。好吧，很有道理。是的，我大概应该闭嘴了。
All you could do is make a volcano or something. It's like things have gotten so tame. Yes. Anyway. I don't disagree, but I am not a lawyer. I will not recommend you teach your kids to make napalm. Okay, fair enough. Yeah, I should probably shut up.
我应该删除我的浏览器历史记录。所以，是的。现在我们有一个非常棒的访谈。所以我们要开始了。好了。大家好。所以我们今天请到了Spring Cloud的首席工程师Spencer Gibb和Pivotal的开发者布道师Mark Heckler，我们将深入探讨Spring框架，这是一个非常酷的技术。我过去绝对用过它。很多人，如果你是Java开发者，你用过它，或者至少听说过它。但现在我们有了专家，他们可以真正告诉我们，填补我们脑海中关于Spring的那种瑞士奶酪式心智模型中的所有漏洞。
I should delete my browser history. So, yeah. So now we have a really cool interview. And so we're gonna take it away. All right. Hey, everyone. So we're here with Spencer Gibb, who's a principal engineer at Spring Cloud and Mark Heckler, who's a developer advocate for Pivotal. And we're going to talk all about the Spring Framework, which is something pretty cool. I've definitely used it in the past. A lot of people, if you're a Java developer, you've used it or you at least know about it. But now we have experts who can really tell us, kind of fill in all of the holes in our sort of Swiss cheese mental model of Spring.
所以，Mark和Spencer，简单自我介绍一下吧。你们在Pivotal做什么，你们对Spring框架的哪些部分最感兴趣？好的，我想我先开始吧。我叫Mark Heckler。我是Pivotal的开发者布道师。Pivotal涉及的领域非常广泛。Pivotal可能最为人熟知的两件大事，在众多事务中，是Spring框架和Spring开发产品组合，以及Pivotal Cloud Foundry。我这两方面都有涉猎，但我主要关注Spring产品组合。
So kind of, you know, Mark and Spencer, kind of just give a brief intro of yourselves. Kind of what do you do at Pivotal and what parts of the Spring Framework you're most interested in? Okay, well, I guess I will start. My name is Mark Heckler. I'm a developer advocate for Pivotal. Pivotal covers a lot of ground. And the two big things that Pivotal is probably known for, among many things, are the Spring Framework and the and the Spring portfolio of development products, as well as Pivotal Cloud Foundry. I do kind of deal with both of those, but I focus primarily on the Spring portfolio.
我有机会走出去，我的背景是开发，所以我得以与许多开发者交流，了解他们在做什么，以及他们如何希望能用Spring做得更好。我叫Spencer Gibb。我是Spring Cloud的负责人之一。Spring Cloud专注于消除分布式系统带来的一些样板代码。通常当你采用微服务架构时，你就会发现自己处于这种境况，我们试图消除一些因此带来的痛苦
And I get to go out and my background is in development, so I get to go out and talk to a lot of developers about what they're doing and how they can hopefully do it better with Spring. My name is Spencer Gibb. I'm one of the leads on Spring Cloud. Spring Cloud is focused on eliminating some of the boilerplate that comes with distributed systems. Often you find yourself in that situation when you have a microservice architecture and we try and eliminate some of the heartache
和问题。酷，这说得通。所以当你们说Spring Cloud时，这是指与AWS对接，还是更偏向MapReduce Spark类型的高计算？Spring Cloud的核心处理诸如服务发现和配置、分布式配置
and problems that come from that. Cool, that makes sense. So when you say Spring Cloud, is this like interfacing with AWS or is this more MapReduce Spark type computing? Spring Cloud, the core of it deals with things like service discovery and configuration, distributed configuration
以及断路器以及诸如此类的事情，无论你运行在哪个云基础设施上。明白了。酷。非常酷。所以如果你必须给出，我的意思是，我知道Spring是一个庞大的框架。我见过很多来自Spring的东西。比如我从Spring用过的一个东西是OAuth插件，你可以通过Facebook登录，通过Google登录。
and circuit breakers and different things like that, regardless of which cloud infrastructure you run on. Gotcha. Cool. Very cool. So if you had to give, I mean, I know Spring is just a massive framework. I've seen so many things come from Spring. Like one thing I used from Spring was an OAuth plugin where you could log in through Facebook, log in through Google.
但Spring做了很多不同的事情。如果你必须用几句话来描述Spring框架，你会怎么做？好吧，我先来试一下，如果我有什么遗漏的地方，Spencer可以来补充。Spring Framework一开始是作为一种修复企业级Java糟糕处境的方法出现的。当然，它不断发展以提供许多功能。然后，当然，整体拼图中的各种不同组件或不同部分应运而生，以解决不同的需求。
But Spring does so many different things. If you had to sort of describe the Spring Framework in a few sentences, how could you do that? Well, I'll take a first shot at this, and Spencer can fill in wherever I may leave a gap. The Spring Framework kind of started off as a way to fix a very bad situation with enterprise Java. And, of course, it grew to provide a lot of capabilities. And then, of course, various different components or different parts of the overall puzzle came into being to solve different needs.
所以你有像Spring Cloud这样的东西，它涵盖了云开发的命令式模型。你有像新的Project Reactor这样的东西，它涵盖了响应式领域，你还有Spring Data、Spring Cloud OAuth、Spring Security以及其他几个被孵化的项目。如果看到了足够的价值，如果有很多人拥抱这一点并认为它满足了真正的需求。当然，通常这会被折叠到未来的整体项目或产品组合中
So you have things like Spring Cloud, which covers an imperative model of cloud development. And you have things like the new project reactor, which covers a reactive space, and you have Spring Data and Spring Cloud OAuth and Spring Security and several other projects which were incubated. And if sufficient value is seen, if there's a lot of folks embrace that and see that as meeting a real need. Of course, usually that's kind of folded into the overall project going forward or the portfolio going
向前发展。从我最近的角度来看，我一直认为Spring是一个消除样板代码的工具，消除那些你一遍又一遍重复做的事情，我记不清团队里的哪个人说的了，但当你使用Spring，特别是Spring Boot和Spring Cloud时，这就像与整个Spring团队进行结对编程，对吧？他们是你的团队的一部分，你不用担心他们所做的所有那些事情。你可以专注于詹姆斯·沃特斯（James Waters）所说的价值线，对吧？无论你的项目做什么，是独特的东西，而不是所有这些每个人一遍又一遍在做的事情。是的，这说得通。
forward. From my point of view recently, I've thought of Spring as it's a tool to eliminate boilerplate, eliminate those repetitive things you do over and over and over um i can't remember which which person on the team said it but when you use spring and in particular spring boot and spring cloud it's like pair programming with the whole spring team right you're nice they're part of they're part of your team and you don't have to worry about all those things that they do. You get to focus on what James Waters calls the value line, right? Whatever your project does that is unique rather than all this stuff that everybody does over and over and over. Yeah, that makes sense.
我的意思是，我知道让我开始思考这方面事情的第一件事之一，就是当我发现了协议缓冲区（Protocol Buffers）或Thrift，或者Avro，或者任何这些容器框架之一时。我意识到，哦，我不需要编写2000行代码来把这些Java对象放到硬盘上或者发送给另一台计算机。他们已经找到了某种方式
I mean, I know just one of the first things that made me think about things along that line is when I found out about protocol buffers or Thrift or one of these, Avro or any of these sort of container frameworks. And I realized, oh, I don't have to write 2000 lines of code to take these Java objects and put them on the hard drive or send them to another computer. That they've just found some way
我可以写几行代码，然后协议缓冲区就会为我做大量的工作。Spring也是如此，相信我，你不想去了解OAuth 2、重定向URL和令牌。你不想去处理任何那些东西。我敢肯定，不管是谁在听节目。那不会是你们业务的核心。
where I can write a couple of lines of code and protocol buffers will do so much work for me. And Spring is much the same way where, trust me, you don't want to learn about OAuth 2 and redirect URLs and tokens. And you don't want to have to deal with any of that. I'm pretty sure that won't be whoever's listening. That won't be core to your business.
你的业务将是关于制作一个酷炫的应用程序或网站，你正在向广大受众提供一些娱乐或教育，而不是去试图理解令牌，所以使用Spring框架的那个元素可以极大地帮助这一点。那么Spring与Apache Commons有什么关系呢？Apache Commons也算是一个大型的库集合，它们为开发者提供了支持。所以Spring只是一个类似的载体，但更倾向于企业级，还是说它们之间有什么区别？好吧，我先来接话。我觉得各种组件带来的很多价值是一种有主见的（opinionated）方法。有时你会听到这个，很多时候人们在做某事时，我们试图做的是提供一条非常清晰的路径，以一种阻力最小的路径来涵盖那80%到90%的用例。
Your business is going to be about making a cool app or or a website you're providing some entertainment or some education uh to to you know a broad set of people not you know trying to understand tokens and so using you know that element of the spring framework uh can greatly help that So how does Spring then relate to, say, Apache Commons, right? Apache Commons is also sort of a large collection of libraries that, you know, kind of enable developers. So is Spring just like kind of a similar vehicle, but more geared to enterprise, or kind of what are the differences there? Well, I'll tag in first on this. I feel like a lot of the value that the various components bring to the mix is an opinionated approach. Sometimes you hear that, and a lot of times people of doing something, what we try to do is provide a very clear-cut path with kind of a path of least resistance to cover that 80% to 90% of use cases.
因此，对于我们在各个地方都非常相似的许多事情，我们希望用极少量的代码让你非常容易地做到这一点。但在过去，那些框架糟糕的旧时光里，通常你只有一种方法来做事情。那就是框架的方式。如果你不按框架的方式做，那就太糟了，你知道的，你用那个特定的工具集就是搞不定。但通过有主见的方法，我们可以非常轻松地解决那80%到90%的用例。然而，如果你仍然需要打破常规，我们希望不碍你的事，并允许你同样满足这些需求。
So for the many, many things that we do that are very similar across the board, we want to make that very easy for you to do with a minimal amount of code. But in the old days, the old bad old days of frameworks, typically you had one way to do things. And that was the framework way. And if you didn't do it, the framework way tough, you know, you just couldn't get it done with that that particular tool set. But with an opinionated approach, we want to solve that 80 to 90% use case very easily. And yet still, if you need to color outside those lines, we want to get out of your way and allow you to meet those needs as well.
所以当你谈到像Apache Commons或其他开源库时，通常它们要么试图——我这里说的比较笼统——它们要么试图提供许多不同的方法来做事情，要么提供一种方法来做事情。我们试图非常容易地提供那一种方法，同时仍然为你提供逃生舱口，让你相当容易地做其他事情，只需你付出一点点努力。Spring框架的核心是一个依赖注入框架，然后在其上添加了东西，比如Spring MVC，即Web框架，以及你刚才谈到的东西，比如安全，还有诸如Spring Data和其他东西。而其中的每一个本身都可以具有相当的规模和复杂性
So when you talk about things like Apache Commons or other open source libraries, typically they'll either try to, and I'm kind of painting with a broad brush here, but they try to either provide a lot of different ways to do things or one way to do things. We try to provide that one way very easily and yet still provide you that escape hatch to let you do the other things fairly easily but with a little more effort on your part and spring framework you know at its core is a dependency injection framework and then things have been added on right like uh spring mbc which is the the web framework and things like you've talked about, like security, and there's also things like Spring Data and other things. And each one of those in and of itself could be of comparable size and complexity
类似于Apache Commons的东西。Spring Boot的负责人之一菲尔·韦伯（Phil Webb）有一些幻灯片，他描绘了Spring框架的图景，他放了一张做蛋糕所需的各种原料的照片，对吧？鸡蛋、面粉、糖、香草以及所有这些不同的东西。Spring Boot就是一个烤好的蛋糕，对吧？就像Mark谈到的那样，它能让你完成大部分工作。像Spring Cloud这样的项目，Spring Boot专注于单个进程，而Spring Cloud则专注于多个进程以及这些进程之间的高级协调。酷，这说得通。所以通常当你想到Spring时，你会想到网络，你知道的，网络框架和网络服务。这看起来
to something like Apache Commons. And there's some slides from Phil Webb one of the the leads of Spring Boot which he he paints a picture of spring framework he puts up a picture of a bunch of ingredients for a cake right eggs flour sugar vanilla all those different things Spring Boot is a baked cake, right? Like Mark talked about, it's the, it will get you most of the way there. And projects like Spring Cloud, where Spring Boot focuses on an individual process, Spring Cloud kind of focuses on multiple processes and the coordination between those processes at a high level. Cool, that makes sense. So typically when you think about Spring, you think about kind of web, you know, web frameworks and web services. And that seems
就像是它的许多起源。听起来最初的起源是依赖注入。但当我发现它时，它已经进入了网络领域。但现在听起来它甚至超越了网络，走向了Java工程师的许多其他典型用例？是的，在网络之外还有诸如Spring Data之类的事情，Spring使用了一种模板模式，使得与不同技术的接口变得简单。有用于与RabbitMQ接口的JDBC template和Rabbit template，但也有与不同类型数据库接口的接口，NoSQL、键值存储、
like that was a lot of the origin. It sounds like the origin was initially dependency injection. But when I found out about it, it had gotten into web. But now it sounds like it's going even kind of beyond web to a lot of other kind of typical use cases for Java engineers? Yeah, there's beyond web things like Spring Data, where Spring has a template pattern that it uses that makes interfacing with different technologies simple. There's JDBC template and Rabbit template for interfacing with RabbitMQ, but there's also interfaces to different styles of databases, NoSQL, key value stores,
文档存储。有流相关的技术，所以使用诸如Kafka、当然还有RabbitMQ和Redis等技术的接口。因此它变得非常广泛且有用，从大型项目到小型项目都可以使用
document stores. There are stream-related technologies, so using interfacing with technologies like Kafka and, of course, RabbitMQ and Redis. So it's becoming quite broad and useful in anywhere from large projects to small ones
因为Spring Boot易于使用。酷，这说得通。所以有Pivotal，这是引领Spring发展潮流的公司。Pivotal目前还真正参与了哪些其他项目？嗯，Pivotal是，我想总的来说，是Apache Tomcat的巨大贡献者。我们还有几个项目，要么被我们收编进行管理，要么是我们自己创建的，比如Redis、RabbitMQ、GreenPlum。我们还贡献了大量的代码，
because of the ease of use of Spring Boot. Cool. That makes sense. So there's Pivotal, which is the sort of company that is leading the charge on Spring. What are some other projects that Pivotal is really involved in right now? Well, Pivotal are, I guess, as a whole, huge contributors to Apache Tomcat. We also have several projects that we've either brought under our fold in terms of stewardship or have created ourselves, things like Redis, RabbitMQ, GreenPlum. We also have contributed a lot of code,
投入了大量的时间和承诺给Cloud Foundry。Cloud Foundry由一个基金会运营。你有像IBM、HP、GE、CenturyLink，当然还有Pivotal等大玩家，以及许多其他人，他们联合起来创建一个开源云平台。Pivotal是其中的一个参与者，但也是一个非常强有力的参与者，同样有时间和资源支持。所以这只是一点点。但是，当然，Spring工程师，Pivotal的工程师总的来说
a lot of hours and time and commitment to Cloud Foundry. Cloud Foundry is run by a foundation. You have big players like IBM and HP and GE and CenturyLink and, of course, Pivotal, among many others, who have come together to create an open source cloud platform. Pivotal is one player in that, but a very strong player in that as well, again, with time and resources behind it. So that's kind of a smattering. But, of course, Spring engineers, Pivotal engineers in general
他们涉足很多事情并做出贡献。开源精神与公司以及我们所有人都交织在一起。所以我认为我们都试图在力所能及的地方做出贡献。酷，这说得通。我想你刚才暗示过这一点，但是谁是Spring的大用户呢？谁是那些拥有最多服务器、P90的用户，对吧？那些拥有使用Spring框架最多的10%服务器和用户的群体是谁？
have their hands in a lot of things and contribute. The open source ethos is kind of interwoven with the company and with all of us. So I think we all try to contribute where we can. Cool, that makes sense. I think you kind of alluded to this, but who are sort of the big users of Spring? Who are sort of your heavy hitters who have the most, the P90, right? The people who have the 10% most servers and users who are using the Spring framework?
我没有庞大的客户名单，但我可以告诉你一些我访问过的公司，他们公开了我可以告诉你一些我访问过的公司，他们公开宣布他们使用了Cloud Foundry以及Spring。所以我亲自访问过Comcast，上周刚去过福斯（Ford）。所以有一些非常大的公司在使用Spring和Cloud Foundry。是的，就在我脑海中，我可以想到像Home Depot、Allstate、JPMC这样的人。我知道我实际上四处寻找过，因为你在不同的地方会发现Spring框架、Spring Boot和各种组件在使用，而这些地方你可能不会听到太多，
I don't have a huge list of customers, but I can tell you some that I've visited that have publicly I can tell you some that I've visited that have publicly announced they're using a use of Cloud Foundry and Spring as well. So I've personally visited Comcast and was just at Ford last week. So there are some really big companies that are using Spring and Cloud Foundry as well. Yeah, just off the top of my head, I can think of folks like Home Depot, Allstate, JPMC. I know I actually kind of went looking because you find the Spring framework and Spring Boot and various components that are in use in different places that you wouldn't necessarily hear a lot about,
但只要任何地方有对强大的后端处理或云能力的需求，无论是在内部部署（on-premises）还是在公有云中，你通常都会看到Spring在某种程度上被采用。我曾经历过，在幕后做了一点搜索，发现硅谷和全国各地你能想象到的大多数主要玩家都在某种程度上使用过Spring。因此，至于这些不同公司之间的渗透率，我不知道，但我知道它在你能想象到的几乎任何地方都被广泛使用。
but they're just any place that has a need for a robust backend processing or a cloud capabilities in-house or on-premises or in public cloud, you typically see Spring employed in some capacity or another. And I kind of went through the, did a little bit of behind the scenes searching and saw that most of your major players that you might imagine in Silicon Valley and throughout the country have used Spring in some capacity or other. So as far as the penetration among those different companies, I have no idea, but I do know that it's pretty widely used pretty much anywhere you can
是的。有一些中国的大公司也在使用Spring，而且我知道很多使用Spring的公司，他们并不是Pivotal的付费客户。
imagine. Yeah. There are some, some large Chinese companies that, that use spring as well. And, and I know a lot of companies that use spring, they just aren't paying customers to pivotal.
所以没有多少与此相关的公关。因此它在许多地方被广泛使用，没有多少公关与此相关的公关。因此它在许多地方被广泛使用。是的，这完全说得通。是的，就像你看到的每一个，可能有49个在使用它，但你不知道，因为它是开源的，对吧？直到你收到来自某个你从未知道其存在的公司的40,000行代码的拉取请求（pull request），对吧？完全正确。
So there's not a lot of PR that goes with that. So there it's, it's in loose's not a lot of PR that goes with that. So it's in loose use in a lot of places. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Yeah, it's like for everyone you see, there's probably 49 that are using it that you don't know about because it's open source, right? Until you get that pull request with 40,000 lines from some company that you never knew existed, right? Exactly.
所以假设有人刚大学毕业。他们想建立他们的第一个酷炫的网站，他们想使用Spring.他们可能懂Java，但除了这个播客外，从未听说过Spring。你会推荐他们如何开始？Spring的“Hello World”是什么？嗯，我认为我们做得很好的一件事是创建了一些非常好的精简入门指南，以及一些更深入的指南。如果你去spring.io斜杠guides，我相信是这样的，我会验证这一点，
So let's say someone is fresh out of college. They want to build their first kind of cool website, and they want to use Spring. They might know Java, but I've never heard of Spring other than this podcast. How would you recommend them to get started? What's sort of the hello world of Spring? Well, one thing that I think we do a really nice job with is creating some really good bite-sized getting started guides, as well as some more in-depth guides. And if you go to spring.io slash guides, I believe it is, I'll verify that and
我们可以在节目笔记中链接到它。但我们有很多精简的用例，有人可以问，天哪，我如何创建一个REST API？我如何与Redis协作？我如何与Kafka协作？我如何使用Spring Data在后台接入NoSQL数据存储？我们有这些精简的指南一步一步引导你，通常使用Spring Boot，因为Spring Boot使这一切更容易消费和接近。因此，你通常用来根据你指定的依赖项创建一个空壳项目的网站是Spring Initializer网站，即start.spring.io，它不生成任何代码，但它会创建一个壳项目，为你的应用程序提供一个奔跑的起点。然后，当然，入门指南会给你那种陪伴你、手把手带你开始使用的体验。然后，当然，我们有一个非常好的Spring Central Twitter账户，以及一个很好的YouTube频道，为你提供许多非常短以及非常深入的视频指南，让你上手并运行。
we can link to that in the show notes. But we have a lot of bite-sized use cases that someone can say, well, gosh, how do I create a REST API? How do I work with Redis? How do I work with Kafka? How do I maybe plug into a NoSQL data store behind the scenes using Spring Data? And we have these kind of bite-sized guides that step you through that, typically using Spring Boot, because Spring Boot makes all of this much more easily consumable and approachable. So the website you typically start with to create an empty shell project based on dependencies you specify is the Spring Initializer site, which is start.spring.io, which doesn't generate any code, but it will create a shell project that gives you kind of a running start at your application. And then, of course, the getting started guides give you that kind of walk alongside you holding your hand and get you started with it. And then of course, we have a really good Spring Central Twitter account, as well as a good YouTube channel, which give you a lot of very short as well as very in depth video guides to kind of get you up and running and started.
当然，除此之外，我们在Gitter上，我们在Twitter上，我们在你可能想要联系的任何地方。我们鼓励社区这样做，因为有时有人会提出一个我们可能从未想过的问题，或者这可能不是一个典型的用例，但这是我们想要考虑的事情.或者他们可能，就像你说的，用拉取请求来ping我们。我总是告诉人们，获取二进制文件，玩转二进制文件，获取代码，你知道的，玩转代码，浏览代码。如果你看到我们漏掉了什么，让我们知道。如果你可能想提交一个拉取请求，也这样做，因为这一切都在那里。我们，你知道的，这就是你如何加速运行并做有用的事情的方法，就是开始使用它。所以我们也尽量让这变得容易。
And of course, past that, we're on Gitter, we're on Twitter, we're everywhere you might want to reach out. And we encourage that from the community because sometimes someone will come up with a question that we've perhaps never thought of or perhaps it's not a typical use case, but it's something we want to consider. Or they may, again, as you said, ping us with a pull request. And I always tell people, get the bits, play with the bits, get the code, you know, play with the code, look through the code. And if you see something we're missing, let us know. And if you maybe want to submit a pull request, do that as well, because it's all out there. We, you know, that's that's kind of how you get up to speed and running and do useful things is to start working with it. So we try to make that easy as well.
酷，这说得通听起来很棒。我们肯定会在节目笔记中包含这些链接。所以如果你在听，并且想查看这些指南，最好的方法可能是点击播客笔记中的节目笔记链接，然后我们在那里会有链接。我知道Apache有一个Apache孵化器项目，专门针对那些还没有准备好登上黄金时间或企业应用的项目。所以如果你能透露点内幕，现在有什么令人惊叹的Spring项目正在孵化中，人们可以真正期待的吗？我不知道有什么东西是保密的。我们今年计划实施的很多事情，我们在Spring One Platform上讨论过，这是我们每年举办一次的Spring和Cloud Foundry会议。
Cool. That makes sense. That sounds great. We'll definitely include those links on the show notes. So if you're listening and you want to check out those guides, probably the best way would be to click on the show notes link in the podcast notes, and then we'll have links over there. So I know that Apache has the Apache sort of incubator for projects that are kind of not really ready for primetime or not really ready for enterprise. So if you could spill the beans, what's sort of an amazing kind of spring project that's in incubation right now that people can really look forward to? I don't know that there's much that's under wraps. A lot of what we plan on implementing this year, we talked about at Spring One Platform, which is our Spring and Cloud
所以当时讨论了很多事情，并且大致给出了路线图。但正在进行的一些事情中，Spring 5正在顺利进行中，有许多特性。它将以Java 8为基线，这与旧版本中的6、7和8支持相比是一个相当大的转变。然后Mark之前稍微提到了一点，但有一个响应式特性。
Foundry conference that happens once a year. And so a lot of things were talked about then, and the roadmap was given generally. But some of the things that are ongoing, Spring 5, which is well underway, has a number of stories. It will be a baseline of Java 8, which is a fairly large shift from the 6, 7, and 8 support in the older lines. And then Mark alluded to it a little bit before, but there's a reactive story.
因此，允许以非阻塞方式访问资源，这将贯穿整个Spring Framework。他们的Spring Boot 2版本将在此基础上构建并具有...有一个新的...如果你以前用过Spring MVC，如果你见过的话，你会有基于注解的方式来制作Web服务。但也将有一种函数式的方式来制作Web服务。
So allowing access to resources in a non-blocking manner that will be throughout Spring Framework. Their Spring Boot version 2 will build upon that and have a... There's a new... If you've worked with Spring MVC before, you kind of have the annotation-based way of doing web services, if you've seen that. But there will also be a functional way of doing web services.
因此，其中一些人可能在习惯于此的其他函数式语言方面有经验，特别是配合Java 8。他们将能够拥有类似的体验，同时拥有Spring Framework给你带来的所有相同历史和稳定性。酷。太棒了。是的，我真的很喜欢，我的意思是，我用过响应式编程。我以前在JavaScript端用过Angular。我见过React。我认为有一个Java RX或类似的东西。
So some of those people that may have experience in another functional language that is used to that, especially with Java 8. They'll be able to have a similar experience while having all of the same history and stability that Spring Framework gives you. Cool. That's awesome. Yeah, I really love the, I mean, I've used reactive programming. I've used Angular before on JavaScript side. I've seen React. There's, I think, a Java RX or something like that.
RX Java。对，RX Java。我其实没用过，但我很喜欢这个想法。它有点像一个带有许多公式的Excel电子表格，当你更改数字时，其他一切都会神奇地计算出来，对吧？所以这很有吸引力。是的，最初的响应式扩展来自微软，网飞（Netflix）的人决定他们想要类似的东西，但他们是重度的JVM用户，所以他们创建了RxJava，现在有许多
RX Java. RX Java, that's right. I haven't actually used it, but I love the idea. It's kind of like an Excel spreadsheet with a bunch of formulas, and when you change the numbers, everything else just magically is computed, right? So there's a lot of appeal to that yeah the the original reactive extensions came were from microsoft and the folks at netflix decided they they wanted something similar but they were heavy jvm users so they created RxJava and now there are a number of
各种语言的响应式实现，所以，是的，事实上有一个响应式流（Reactive streams）项目，它是其中一些项目之间的互操作性接口，所以
reactive implementations in various languages and so yeah it's in fact there's a reactive streams project which is an interoperability interfaces between some of these projects so
例如，如果你有一个RxJava Observable，但你正在使用，你想去一个Reactor Flux，虽然这些并不重要，但它们都实现了你可以从中获得一些兼容性的接口。酷。太棒了。除了Spring Framework，你还希望听众查看哪些其他东西？我们提到了Cloud Foundry。这绝对是一个值得查看的好东西。
for example if you have an RxJava observable, but you're using, you want to go to a reactor flux, which those don't matter, but there are interfaces that they both implement that you can get some compatibility between them. Cool. That's awesome. So besides Spring Framework, what other things do you want kind of listeners to check out? And we mentioned Cloud Foundry. That's definitely a good one to
还有其他Pivotal正在研发的事情吗，或者仅仅是那些你觉得拥有这个令人惊叹的工具、库或语言，而你觉得它被忽视了，就像一个无名英雄，你想提出来的？嗯，我又要插话了。对我来说选择最爱有点难，你知道的，你总是从一个父母那里听到这话，我想，虽然我不是其中任何一个的父亲，我只是众多受益者之一，可以说是狂热的粉丝。但你在Spring框架中、Spring产品组合中有太多东西，它们被开发出来是为了解决真正的需求。在很多方面，它们注定是干粗活的马，而不是赛马。我一直回到Spring Data。我想Spencer也提到过这一点。
check out. Are there any other things that Pivotal is working on or just things where you kind of have this amazing tool or library or language and uh and uh you feel like it it uh is neglected like an unsung hero uh that that that uh you'd want to bring up well i i'll jump in here again it's kind of hard for me to choose favorites you know you always hear that from a parent i guess but uh although i'm not i'm not really the father of any of this, I just am one of the many, many, many beneficiaries, really, and ardent fans, so to speak. But you have so many things in the Spring framework in general, in the Spring portfolio, that were developed to solve a real need. They're meant to be workhorses, not racehorses in a lot of ways. I keep going back to Spring data. I think Spencer's
它不是特别性感。它不一定是那种你真正会因为使用它而感到兴奋的东西。只是它工作得太好了，以至于你发现自己一次又一次地回到它身边，为各种项目使用它。我看到我们的很多产品组合都在解决非常强烈而紧迫的需求，但那里没有太多花哨的噱头。它只是把一个空缺填补得太完美了。我有点兴奋的一件事是那个响应式故事，因为长期以来，我认为Java生态系统在响应式方面有点吃亏。当然，RxJava在这方面是一个非常显着的例外。但通过Project Reactor，
mentioned that too. It's not overly sexy. It's not necessarily something that you'd really get excited about using per se. It's just that it works so well that you find yourself coming back to it and coming back to it over and over for projects. And I see a lot of our portfolio is solving really strong burning needs, but there's not a lot of sizzle there. It just fills a gap so well. The one thing that I'm kind of excited about is that reactive story, because for a long time, I think the Java ecosystem has kind of taken it on the chin on the reactive side of things. And, of course, RxJava being a very noticeable exception in that regard. But with Project Reactor,
我们实际上在整个Spring框架中实现响应式功能，从最底层（存储数据）一直到Web客户端。所以这是一个极其艰巨的任务，我们正在与已经到位的、经过十多年（显著超过十年）实战考验的命令式模型并行实现这一点。我们并行实现这些，以便人们可以带上他们的机构知识、现有知识，并使之立即应用，而不必把所有东西都转换成非此即彼的局面。所以这让我很兴奋，因为我可以在有意义的时候使用有意义的工具。这也是我们所有人想要的，对吧？
we're actually implementing reactive capabilities throughout all of the Spring framework, all the way from the lowest tier, you know, storing the data, all the way up through to a web client. So that is, it's a Herculean task, and we're implementing that in parallel with the imperative model that we already have in place that's kind of battle
是的，绝对的。我知道有过，我的意思是，每次一个框架或语言做了不向后兼容的事情时，总是极其痛苦。我的意思是，作为一个社区，我们仍然无法超越Python 2，让每个人都用上Python 3还是很困难，这已经，我不知道具体多久了，但至少得有5年甚至更久，Angular也是如此
tested for well over a decade, significantly over a decade. And we're implementing those in parallel so that people can bring their institutional knowledge, their existing knowledge, and have it immediately apply and to not have to convert everything over to where it's an all or nothing. So that kind of excites me because I can use the tool that makes sense when it makes sense to use it. And that's all any of us want, right? Yeah, absolutely. I know there have been, I mean, every time, you know, a framework or language does something that isn't backwards compatible it's always extremely painful I mean we still can't
我的意思是Angular升级到2.0，而且不向后兼容。这真的很难把整个社区迁移过去。是的，你不想失去你作为开发者培养出来的专业知识。你不想觉得，好吧，这很棒，但到目前为止我所做的一切，直接扔掉吧，因为一切在一夜之间全变了。你想利用所有这些整洁的新东西，但你又不想觉得你必须扔掉你所学到的一切、教训以及你为了到达那里而赢得的战斗，这就是我们希望通过以并行打包的方式提供两全其美的优势来实现的目标，所以酷，嗯，所以，在我们在结束之前关于Pivotal的几个问题，嗯，
just as a community get beyond Python 2 it's still hard to get everyone on Python 3 it's been what I don't know exactly how long but it's got to be at least 5 years if not longer and the same with Angular
你知道，Pivotal在哪里？你们在招人吗？而且，无论你们是否在招人，在Pivotal工作最好的地方是什么？如果不招人，你可以让所有人都嫉妒。如果你们在招人，这可能是一个卖点。我们在招人，据我所知，我们专门为我所知道的Spring团队在招人。所以我们在招人。Pivotal脱胎于被EMC和VMware收购的不同项目。
I mean Angular went to 2.0, and it's not backwards compatible. And it's just, it's very hard to migrate the whole community over. Yeah, and you don't want to lose that expertise that you've developed as a developer. You don't want to feel like, well, that's great, but everything I've done up to this point, just throw it away, because everything changed out from under me overnight. You want to take advantage of all the neat new stuff but you don't want to feel like you have to throw away all that you've learned and the lessons and the the battles you've won to get there and that's what we hope to accomplish by providing kind of the best of both worlds uh in parallel packaging so cool um so uh well a couple of questions aboutal before we kind of wrap up, um, uh,
我的意思是，Angular 升级到 2.0 后就不再向下兼容了。而且要让整个社区迁移过去非常困难。是的，作为开发人员，你不想失去你已经培养起来的专业技能。你不想觉得“好吧，这固然很好，但我之前做的一切都得扔掉”，因为一切在一夜之间全变了。你既想利用所有这些酷炫的新东西，又不想觉得自己不得不抛弃学到的所有知识、经验以及为了走到这一步而打赢的胜仗。这正是我们希望通过在并行打包中提供两全其美的方案来实现的目标。嗯，太酷了。那么，在我们结束之前，关于 Pivotal 还有几个问题……
you know, where's Pivotal located? Uh, are you guys hiring? And, uh, uh, whether you're hiring or not, what's the best thing about working at Pivotal? If you're not hiring, you can just make everyone really jealous. Um, if you are hiring, it could be a selling point. We are hiring and I know we're hiring specifically for the Spring team that I know of. So we are hiring. Pivotal came from different projects that had been acquired by EMC and VMware.
Pivotal 总部在哪里？你们在招人吗？不管招不招人，在 Pivotal 工作最棒的地方是什么？如果不招人，你也可以让所有人羡慕嫉妒恨。如果正在招人，这倒可以算是一个卖点。我们在招人，而且据我所知，我们专门在为 Spring 团队招人。所以我们确实在招人。Pivotal 是由被 EMC 和 VMware 收购的不同项目整合而来的。
And so they spun those software projects out into Pivotal. So Pivotal itself is only three or four years old, but the projects that are in them are older than that. I believe headquarters in Silicon Valley with offices all over the world, really, one of the parts of pivotal is a consulting arm they don't they have a different style of of teaching and i saw this at ford rather than just having a class you know a week boot camp where they come in and show you how to their way of doing things the way they like to do things is pair with the company and show them, build something real with them and show them their processes and things, how they do that. So that's one of the things that, that Pivotal does as well. Cool. Sounds good. Great. Thank you so much for your time. This is
因此，他们把这些软件项目分拆成立了 Pivotal。所以 Pivotal 本身只有三四年的历史，但其中的项目比这还要古老。我相信总部在硅谷，在世界各地都有办公室。实际上，Pivotal 的一部分是一个咨询部门，他们有不同的教学风格，我在福特看到了这一点——不是只上一个星期的训练营课程，让他们进来展示他们的做事方式，他们喜欢的方式是与公司合作并向他们展示，与他们一起构建真实的东西，向他们展示他们的流程和做事方法。所以这也是 Pivotal 的工作之一。太棒了。听起来不错。太好了。非常感谢您抽出时间。这是
super interesting. I've definitely used a lot of the Spring Framework in the past. So, so thank you for building it as well. I've definitely, it's made a lot of projects I've definitely used a lot of the Spring framework in the past, so thank you for building it as well. Definitely, it's made a lot of projects I've built easier. Patrick, do you have anything burning? I feel like I... No, I mean, I think that was awesome. You did a great job. Thank you, everyone, for being on.
超级有趣。我过去绝对用过很多 Spring 框架。所以，也非常感谢你们开发了它。它确实让我的许多项目变得更加容易。帕特里克，你有什么急迫想问的吗？我觉得我……不，我的意思是，我认为这太棒了。你做得很好。谢谢大家参与。
Well, thanks for having us, and thanks to the Spring community for being an awesome community and working with us, and thanks for the Spring community for being an awesome community and working with us and thanks for the pull requests. Alright, we'll keep them coming. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown
嗯，谢谢邀请我们，也谢谢 Spring 社区成为一个出色的社区并与我们合作，谢谢 Spring 社区成为一个出色的社区并与我们合作，还要谢谢你们提交的 Pull Request。好的，我们会继续保持。片头曲是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。《Programming Throwdown》
is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work but you must provide an attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
采用知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混编和改编，但您必须按照协议署名。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。